nud scenes in movies aren't supposed to
be life-threatening except if your name
is Glenn Powell here's how the Top Gun
maverick star nearly died while taking
it all off in his new movie and lived to
tell about it shooting a nude scene is
likely nerve-wracking under the best of
circumstances after all you're
surrounded by a bunch of people with
cameras and have to somehow deliver a
top-notch performance while your whole
butt is hanging out furthermore it
certainly doesn't help if you have to do
the take multiple times Glen Powell
faced an additional challenge while
filming his new romantic comedy anyone
but you alongside Sydney Sweeney during
the New York premiere of the film The
actor told variety that in a scene where
his character frantically disres he
almost tripped and fell to his death as
pal put it taking your clothes off on
the side of a cliff in a hurry is not
safe nobody talks about that safety
issue on set where I almost died falling
off a cliff taking my pants off too fast
but it's a really fun scene so it was
all worth it strip off your clothes as
quickly as possible and and hope you
don't trip and die cuz if you die
wearing only a sock that's one way to be
remembered and that's not what I wanted
to do Powell also told the outlet that
filming a nude scene isn't particularly
sexy in practice largely because you
just feel really dumb in the moment he
added you just have to grip it and rip
it on a scene like that you know you're
not going to leave that filming day
looking cool so you just have to embrace
it however Powell wasn't the only one in
very real danger while filming the scene
in it Powell and Sweeney are hiking
through a wild area in Australia and
worry that a spider might be roaming
underneath his clothes as Sweeney
revealed at the premiere the spider that
was used to shoot the scene actually
took a bite out of her during an
interview on The Tonight Show Sweeney
even showed a behind the-scenes clip of
the biting incident to the host she told
variety there's the spider itself which
actually bit me and that was a whole
thing Sweeney didn't elaborate on what
the whole thing entailed or whether or
not she needed any medical attention
however she went on to add and then we
have the part of Glenn bending over and
me checking to see if there are more
spiders even though sweee is engaged to
restor a tour Jonathan deino the flirty
Vibe between her and and pow throughout
the film's Press tour hasn't gone
unnoticed that said the pair have
repeatedly insisted that they're just
very good friends guys really but we do
love we do love each other and honestly
this is one of the most spectacular
humans I've ever met she's really
incredible a well youall are so cute
together during her red carpet interview
however Sweeney pretty much admitted to
spending a day staring at a naked pal
while filming so information like that
certainly won't help their case Sweeney
even quipped during the red carpet
interview I'm very acquainted with Glenn
now but spider biting incidents aside
fans of Glenn Powell and Sydney Sweeney
still want to know what their new movie
is about anyone but you is a modern take
on William shakespear's comedy much ad
do about nothing this is made apparent
by the characters names Ben played by
Powell and B Sweeney's character which
are a take on benedic and beatric from
the original play the film is a smart
funny spin on the enemies to lovers
Trope that forces Ben and be to pretend
like they're a happy couple predictably
this fake Arrangement gets a little too
real pretty quickly it's a romantic
comedy after all anyone but you hits
theaters on December 22nd
[Music]